so far for every episode I keep thinking
of this moment from Breaking Bad where
Aaron Paul keeps shouting you can't keep
getting
it the person who keeps getting away
with it is Craig Mason and making such a
great adaption with so many wonderful
changes this episode has a perfect
balance of retaining the best moments
from the game while also making some
necessary and well-fitting changes I can
go through them chronologically but I
want to address the biggest and most
impactful ones first which are Joel and
Ellie in this episode we all know that
their relationship from the game to the
show is much different in that Joel is
more closed off towards Ellie this Joel
isn't 100 the same in comparison to the
game and they are making a more real and
grounded Joel for the TV show instead of
a superhero who kills like a hundred
writers and infected throughout the game
some people may dislike this inherent
change but I think it's necessary for
the TV medium because games have the
freedom of not following logic at all
times so giving Joel a new
characteristic of panic attacks I think
is really well fitting for this version
of Joel it makes him more vulnerable and
it shows a weakness that thus makes him
more human Joel doubts himself and the
more he grows attached to Ellie the more
he doesn't think he's up to the task of
taking care of her like I don't think
this is just Joel suddenly being
overcome with age because the Jolly meet
in the beginning of the show is much
more confident instead these panic
attacks are being triggered by him
genuinely being afraid of not being able
to protect Ellie and Tim kind of seeing
Sarah in her this detail about his
character is such a smart point to add
that further punctuates how much he
cares about Ellie I think their
confrontation this episode lands
extremely well because there's always
been friction between Joel and Ellie and
this scene is the climax of that
conflict their Dynamic up until this
point was essentially Joel trying his
best to avoid this type of scenario he
didn't want to become attached to Ellie
given how her mission was what killed
Tess but the inevitability of their bond
is the most endearing aspect of the last
of us not the violence in action
throughout the game as people say
there's a gross lack of in the show the
characters in their Journeys are what
makes the story so amazing and I may get
some hate for it but I I think Joan
Ellie's Arc is better in the show I said
it although it's not done yet obviously
but through this road of conflict and
slow build up of them getting closer
Joel finally becoming the warm surrogate
father is immensely satisfying it feels
much more earned here and you can see
Joel throughout the entire episode
grapple with this conundrum whether it
be in this explosive confrontation or
through more nuanced and detailed
moments which on that front Pedro Pascal
gave an insane performance this episode
both for him and Ellie's scene and
Tommy's seeing him break down and be
this vulnerable was really surprising to
me because Joel never really gets to
this point in the game the show is able
to explore a much deeper character dive
of Joel and the journey we go on with
him for this episode is captivating
because of how outstanding Pedro is as
an actor in Bella Ramsey essentially
matches him at all times casting wise
they have been absolutely perfect and I
saw some people that Bella Ramsay early
on and I think she has more than earned
the role of Ellie for this entire
confrontation an overall set of events
it plays out differently in the game
personally I didn't like how Ellie
suddenly runs off in the video game when
she overhears Joel and Tommy discussing
having Tommy take her I feel like or at
least in the show at this point it would
be a very Juvenile and impractical thing
to do especially since Ellie running off
in the game leads to Joel and Tommy
having to fight through tons of writers
to get to her if anything I feel like
they kind of use that plot point in the
game to introduce more gameplay and if
it was translated directly over to the
show then it would have felt weird Bella
Ramsay has been very adult-like and
practical and I can't see her here just
running away because the whole thing
she's afraid of is being alone and she'd
be putting herself in danger and the
loved ones that chased after her in
danger too so again I think the change
of having Ellie embracing the cold
reality of Joel leaving her is more
heartbreaking and also leads to a
satisfying moment of Ellie immediately
choosing Joel to take her when he offers
her the choice this overall payoff is so
gratifying because of the long road it
took to get here it makes you feel so
warm and moved by their happy scenes
together just them shooting targets
alone I can watch for hours and they are
such an amazing Duo they can both hit
the dramatic lows of their relationship
while also portraying an immense sense
of love between each other for this
little sequencer travel Montage of sorts
I couldn't escape the Infectious
happiness that they were constantly
exuding and although I've seen people
say that the pacing really picks up here
I think it makes for a more tragic
ending from that fast pace because Joel
and Ellie are finally on loving terms so
the fact that that is suddenly ripped
away from us makes the ending land even
harder we were just given the most
Blissful aspect of the show so when the
creators take it away from us it makes
the ending even more depressing Craig
mazing could have written a much longer
Journey for Joel and Ellie on their way
to the Firefly Outpost but I think this
ending is significantly more impactful
the only aspect about the ending I would
have changed would be to make the
encounter with the writers a bit more
suspenseful but that is honestly an net
pack the scene plays out completely fine
and anyone who is begging for more
action needs to relax because we did
just get one of the best and most insane
action sequences that also happened to
be original in the last episode so
pacing wise there weren't any plot
points that show necessarily skips over
by speeding up their Journey a bit along
with me seeing people already
complaining about how the show gets
boring whenever it's just Joel and Ellie
out in the wilderness together talking
which again is just wild to me because
their Duo is the entire point of the
show in this episode The Writers also
hit all the best bits for Joel and
Ellie's dialogue in the game like Joel
saying he wanted to be a singer and
earlier on in the episode where Ellie
was trying to whistle so it feels like
nothing was really left out
are you all right
I'm trying to learn how to whistle this
attention to detail and understanding of
what makes the game great while also
making outstanding changes really blows
me away because there's so many other
smaller changes that made me love this
episode more than I thought I would like
the opening of the episode where Joel
and Ellie are essentially lost so they
try to get directions from these natives
firstly I think this offers a more
realistic angle in comparison to the
game because there the time Jump drops
them off right at the doorstep to the
dam where they meet Tommy so it feels
very convenient to kind of have wandered
into that situation instead of in the
show where it's shown that they are
genuinely lost and have been searching
for a while then secondly the two
characters Craig Mason introduces here
were surprisingly really funny like I
love how chill the wife was given the
situation and the contrast between her
and her husband was great you're telling
the truth yeah
are you telling me the truth
yeah
the fact that this was just a quick
one-off scene is so impressive from a
writing standpoint these two characters
alone could have carried a much longer
scene if they needed to then the next
change was the circumstances of Joel and
Ellie meeting Tommy's group and really
the entire first 20 minutes is original
but the moment I wanted to address was a
dog scene I was not expecting to almost
have a panic attack for this scene this
moment does feel oddly familiar and I
don't know if I'm forgetting it from the
game or if it's inspired from elsewhere
like a dog sniffing for drugs but the
amount of suspense here really hits you
like a truck especially since we
witnessed most of this moment from the
perspective of Joel as he's losing his
again tying back to his panic
attacks which is totally justified
because I think anyone in this situation
would have probably turned into a puddle
so the twists and seeing that the dog
didn't smell the fungus and reveals
Ellie playing with him was a major
relief then for the last overall change
that really enhances the show is the
fact that we get to see Tommy's
Community we don't actually get to see
this area in the first game and is an
overall great set to have all the
dramatic moments play out for the
episode along with it offering a good
contrast in the way Ali is essentially
grown up and has been living her life
like the shot of her awkwardly sitting
in the crowd of people watching the
movie illustrates that point really well
I also want to go back to Joel and
Tommy's scene since I kind of breezed
over it given I was talking about Joel
and Ellie but this scene is so much more
emotionally pungent in the show since
Joel is being overcome with the fear of
not fully being able to take care of
Ally and seeing him break down here was
so saddening and I love how Craig Mason
actually commits to this scene because
before Joel starts recapping the events
of what happened they cut to Ellie
walking around the square initially I
thought they were cutting away looking
Game of Thrones where Jon Snow is
spilling the beans to his sisters but
here we actually have competent writers
to fully execute and nail the Deep drama
that was available so thank you I said
it earlier but the acting from Pedro is
purely astounding he honestly moved me
to tears in the scene and the fact that
we go from this to the Joel and Ellie
confrontation is a pure Wombo Combo and
probably floored everyone the next year
of the Emmys is going to be an insane
battle between House of the dragon and
the last of us alone overall this
episode is another home run for me and
it manages to hit a major emotional
climax while having a great lineup of
scenes it Nails the suspense the drama
heartbreak has a bit of action
heartwarming moments and a moving ending
that acts as a gut punch since we just
saw the light at the end of the tunnel
the next episode seems to be
predominantly flashback driven with
Ellie which I think is based on the DLC
for the first game so I wonder how
people will treat that episode I don't
know if we're going to have another
episode 3 on our hands in terms of
audience reaction regardless though
thank you for watching and let me know
what you thought about the latest
episode of The Last of Us
foreign